so arnold schwarzenegger says voters uh
were right to retain newsome because gop
feel uh disastrous uh l.a times he was a
governor in 2003 after recall said he
received a relief he was relieved that
gavin newsom kept his job still the
republican added that he was hopeful
that the special election was a wake-up
call for newsome that makes him perform
better the former mr universe who
remains a registered republican despite
his disagreement the former mr universe
this is l.a
former mr olympia and they say mr
universe his disagreements with the
state's party's path was harshly
critical the gop field and the recall is
just disastrous
he says the republican candidates they
did the opposite schwarzenegger said
such as talking about eliminating
environmental law supported by most
californians so uh uh what what is what
is going on with you know this
republican governor in california
supporting with the way newsom handled
california what are you what are your
thoughts about what arnold's saying here
we're seeing it happen right before our
eyes there is no left and right there is
no republican and democrat it's all
window dressing now there are the people
there are the elites who want to control
you the global elites and then there are
the people who just want to be left
alone that the elites refuse to leave
alone i mean look at the emmys in
california these people sit there and
they lecture you on how bad your life is
while they're multi-millionaires
grinding up on each other in twenty
thousand dollar dresses not wearing a
single freaky mess meanwhile the kids in
l.a have got to sit in cubicles and wear
masks all day long like come on it's
insane man we're living in two different
realities this this let them eat brunch
california elite is out of control you
look at a guy like arnold you know how
come he look i actually agree i think
the gop is running bad campaigns the
best thing the gop has done in the last
10 years is just shut up and let people
see what the democratic party really
stands for that tells you how badly that
party is being run on a national and a
state level where the quieter they are
the more people actually listen and
you're seeing f joe biden chants all
over the place but that he also could
have come out and said something to the
effect of hey national media how come
larry elder actually got attacked the
way jesse smilet claims to have gotten
attacked and you guys didn't cover it
jesse smellette claimed to have gotten
juicy juicy
i mean there was a woman
in a gorilla mask
throwing eggs at this dude
a black guy running for public office a
woman a white woman in a gorilla master
was exited this dude and it was on the
news for like half an hour first of all
there's a part about what arnold saying
is right larry elder qualified guy yeah
he just didn't have enough time to
create momentum his concession speech
was really good who's married elder well
larry's uh larry's a g larry's a guy
that he knows how to deliver the message
probably one of the best
uh in america but uh they did not have
five six seven eight guys that wanted to
get out there and do something about it
there were certain people that said that
i would go against the recall
but uh the people that could have
probably wanted
do they really want the life of being
the governor or state of california on
the right i don't know i don't know if
somebody's going to want to do that they
gotta they gotta adjust their strategy
pat they've given up on
the cities if you give up completely on
the cities you can't win
you cannot win by losing the cities by
ninety percent ninety two percent ninety
three percent you just can't do it you
have to fight look that's where the
voter fraud is happening that's where
it's happening voter fraud happens on
both sides but if you can have people go
into a high-rise building and literally
walk door-to-door
ballot harvesting technically illegal it
happens you go door to door and you can
take literally a thousand two thousand
ballots in each building you can knock
out ten thousand people in a day
in a month that's three hundred thousand
people how do you how do you how do you
recover from three hundred thousand
people
if you just give up on the cities you
gave up on the country it's done they
have they've got to get in there and
fight what are your thoughts i mean i i
just know the state of california what
it's like there with the homeless and
the mismanagement of money and going
bankrupt and i mean even me personally
have an employee there and i pay state
tax there as a you know because it's a
nexus for us very you know i don't
understand how they take in so much
money uh yet seem to have no money and
i mean it just california is kind of
mystifying to me i love the i love
visiting i used to love visiting there
um because the weather obviously you
know um but man you go there now and
it's going back to bodybuilding venice
beach you go to gold's gym there's
there's tents tent city all over there
pete needles and people you know plus
you're not paying your fair share really
yeah it's your fault it is you guys
should feel terrible yeah exactly i feel
like soon again pony up guys i mean you
left me up you left so yeah there's no
did you miss it at all no
no i missed the friends i missed the
restaurants i miss the
the community i miss my habits i miss my
drive i miss the
theater i would go to i'm a guy that's a
you know
ritual guy so i like to sit in the same
place same restaurant same waiter
waitress you know there's certain things
i i like and that part i absolutely miss
the weather worldwide probably the best
weather in the world minus a couple
other places that could compete with it
but the politics i'm a freedom guy
and the fact that they don't allow you
to breathe and make a decision for
yourself it's just that automatically
disqualifies from a guy like me being
able to live in a place like that the
whole purpose of why i work my ass off
is because i want to be left alone
that's why i work my ass off is because
just leave me alone let me do my thing
and i'll create value in whatever
community i live in i'm gonna do my best
i'm gonna do my part but if you try to
control too much this reminds me of
going back to iran i have no desire
going back to a place of a lot of
control think about what you just said
and i know it was a joke and it was
hyperbole like you know they they won't
let you breathe like dude they are
literally telling you how and where it's
okay for you to breathe
they're telling you what you can do to
breathe like put a mask over sit down
here if you're standing up you can do
this if you're sitting down you could do
this you know like why is it okay to
take your mask off when you sit down
well because obviously covet is only six
foot high anybody anybody five foot two
or lower they don't have to wear a mask
five foot three or above you know dude
it makes no sense they're just addicted
to the power and then you see the mayor
of san francisco who puts in a mask
mandate tells the entire county of san
francisco the entire city that she's in
front of that she's in control of what
they can and can't do and then goes out
partying with no mask on and then when
they call her on it doesn't even
apologize says the spirit of the night
took me over the spirit of the night i
was feeling the vibe what what is the
meaning of spirit at night
she's talking about what is she talking
about i don't know man dude it's just a
blue pill or the purple tell you bro
anybody listening to this i'll tell you
what next time one of these people and
we all know who we're talking about they
want to come up in your face and they
want to tell you how to live your life
you just look them right in the eye and
you say i'm sorry the spirit of the
night overcame
i'm just going to go ahead and do
whatever i want to do so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you